violence et squeeze et écouter
concernant ma vidéo d'avant-hier je
tenais à m'excuser si j'ai heurté un
grand nombre d'entre vous avec le jeu
japonais exhibitionniste j'aurais dû
dire que ça me semble évident que je
suis complètement contre les hommes qui
font du mal aux femmes
sachez que moi même j'ai des proches qui
ont vécu ça et que je me bats chaque
jour sans en parler devant ma caméra
pour que le moins qui m'entourent soit
un peu meilleur je m'excuse à deux roues
et je vous propose de revenir au rire
parce qu'aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs on jouera jeu qui tombe plutôt
bien on va apprendre à esquiver les
pervers d'un ride with strangers et
pervers comme cet homme vous êtes et
laura c'est donc cette femme et on est
en chemin pour faire une interview
extrêmement importante pour notre
travail
donc on a pris deux voitures et d'un
coup et s'est mis à faire des bruits
bizarres puis elle est tombée en panne
yao qu'une dépanneuse aux alentours pour
nous récupérer donc on doit faire du
stop et monte dans les voitures
d'inconnus en faisant très attention
parce que ça reste des inconnues et du
coup il faut toujours se méfier ne
jamais parler à un inconnu
maman me disait je le fais toujours ok
c'est parti alors tout d'abord on doit
trouver une voiture pour nous emmener à
notre travail
un biocide leur colle à tort mais il
annonce d'une fille qui disparut déjà à
quai au monde est rassuré donc on va
aller sur la route
henri guaino sur carrie regardez nous a
vus et nous a pas vus nous a pas vus
nous apprend il nous a pas vus
attends mon gars c'est un sketch
auraient achoppé une voiture ça fait 10
heures sans déconner bon il a mis son
clignotant au mouillage suis tellement
heureux bonjour monsieur attend dé voir
sa tête je vais pas rentrer dans sa
voiture
mais mon gars mais fois sur l'entrée de
la voiture de cet homme alors si ça se
fait dans la vraie vie vous dit non
vous dites nous vous appelez la police
vous appelez le soin de saper tout y
compris motte maire mais là on est
obligé au fait y avait une autre voiture
donc mais qu'il est réintégré à 8 km 46
copa tu vois ces barrages dont 15 dans
sa voiture il faut qu'on clique sur les
panneaux comme ceci pour aller plus vite
voilà ni plus ni moi on doit de temps en
temps surveiller sa tête en appuyant sur
un cul je réponds est ce que ça te
regarde juste et toi et conduis fdp il
faut que je suis on a eu des fois et le
problème c'est que ça remplit la barque
est tout en haut à gauche je voyais là
bas avec le smiley et quand cette barre
là elle est à fond
et bien je peux plus le regarder il bute
j'ai une réunion importante et je dois
pas être en retard je suis en train de
m'en fuir de chez moi ok on va dire
cachons une réunion l'est ou en pvc quoi
ce bruit il ya un mec dans le coffre
j'ai peur aux puces au final j'ai les
dents longues ou de fous je crois que
peu allumé la radio
ah merde elle marche pas [ __ ] à ok
j'ai pas dû à ces le regarde et du coup
il m'a défoncé suis pas monsieur à la
calvitie s'il vous plaît
ah ok en fait je vais le regarder quand
ils me regardent
sinon ils butent là on peut ouvrir et
partir comme ça pour de la voiture voilà
comment ça a trop parlé moi j'avais peur
voilà donc on se retrouve sur le bord de
la route attendent un mec
bon on va pas retomber sur un
psychopathe c'est pas possible ah mais
c'est peut-être le même remarque c'est
une démo attendez on va voir il est de
retour et il a fait demi-tour dans
l'ombre
oui arrête de faire secte amour j'aime
pas du tout fauqué nombreux dans la
voiture donc du coup la barre de se
marier se remet à zéro
heureusement j'ai regardé au le vieux
pervers [ __ ] [ __ ] vieux gars dans le
arrête de moi mais je t'ai fait en aucun
cas je veux être hébergés par toi mon
gars je réussis l'a échappé à ce gars
non mais je vous le dis hein
pourquoi écouter nous allons y arriver
on va on va libérer le mec du coffre qui
va nous protéger
c'est faux on peut pas le faire
malheureusement donc on voit opta j'aime
pas quand j'ai regardé avec joie qu'il
fait c'est tu sais c'est comme quand tu
regardes une fille dans la vraie vie et
que ton regard croise notion tu paniques
tout de suite quoi à l'italie le gars il
pas rassurant du tout il va falloir
qu'on jette bien je peux plus de cette
tête j'ai envie de pleurer quand il a
fait feu en paix on perd au web
voilà ils allaient attaquer il a il
avait le regard assisteurs de l'homme
celle où atteint c'est pas mal comme je
savais la pression de ou fargo salue
monsieur écoutez je viens de sûreté des
voitures d'un psychopathe
non il ya un mec qui crie la logique où
il va me regarder voir si j'ai capté
qu'un gars qui était dans le coffre
non je me trompe [ __ ] je regardais
trop de films d'action il ya geste juste
des tout petits regards et donne trop de
points ils payent plus tard il m'a fait
peur j'ai cru qu'ils allaient mettre un
coup de poing salo ya un coup de couteau
fausse joie car ce monsieur s'il vous
plaît prenez moi reviendrai jamais ce
qui m'est arrivé est un mec qui m'a pris
en stop c'est un psychopathe j'ai sauté
et là j'ai repris une voiture c'était le
même gars qui m'avait repris en fait on
va juste mais merde je suis trompé de
bouton je voulais ouvrir la fenêtre je
parle je te plaît parle parle j'aime pas
quand tu parles pas à vous avez vu
j'avais raison [ __ ] [ __ ] il vient de
citer un truc de la bible en fait et je
lui ai répondu en mode gentil mais qu'on
n'est jamais allé aussi loin là on a
beau donner question qu'il avait jamais
posé avant on est bien
je vais le dire iam voilà faut que je
fasse ce genre que je suis comme lui
enfin orange ce point est grand show
points soit à face qui interroge saute
je saute à 12 mois suivants
mon dieu on arrive dans un tunnel au nom
pour a pu sauter de la voiture par
contre au on est baisé on est baisé ça
va être le même ressort son histoire de
il a fait un pacte avec dieu pour purger
les chais pas quoi on n'est jamais allé
aussi loin la note record avec on allait
super loin regarder la barre juste
réaction des plus totales alors accélère
vieux papy qui ont débordé bon déborder
bon ben on est là on va super vite mais
qu on voit les gens c'est bien de ça
dont je dispose a pu sega n'hésitez pas
à aller mais comme d'habitude et puis
écoutez si c'est assez original comme je
sais un mix entre une sorte de scénario
à base de céréales killer eiffage n'a
pas de frais 10
on n'a malheureusement pas réussi à
s'échapper mais on est quand même allé
loin [ __ ] de tracer le pont et où
c'était pas mal on peut être fiers de
nous merci à vous regarder on se
retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo portez
vous bien chaud monfils